[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien Ihnen allen einen guten
Abend und alles sportliche später mit
Kristin Otto vor allem Fußball guten
Abend dieser 8 mai ist ein
geschichtsträchtiger wegen des
internationalen kriegsgedenkens außerdem
wurde im Norden gewählt schauen wir
gemeinsam auf die Themen
klarer Wahlsieg für Daniel Günther bei
der Landtagswahl in Schleswig-Holstein
wird die CDU stärkste Kraft
Gedenken an das Weltkriegsende vor 77
Jahren ein 8 mai wie kein anderer so
Bundeskanzler Scholz mit Blick auf den
Krieg in der Ukraine
und Jubel in Gelsenkirchen Schalke 04
kehrt mit dem Sieg gegen St Pauli nach
nur einem Jahr zurück in die erste
fußball-Bundesliga
[Musik]
bevor wir zum internationalen
weltkriegsgedenken kommen mit wichtigen
reden die die Brücke vom Krieg damals
zum Krieg heute schlagen erst der Blick
zur Landtagswahl nach Schleswig-Holstein
in den Umfragen hat es sich schon
abgezeichnet und so ist es dann auch
gekommen
CDU-Ministerpräsident Daniel Günther
kann mit einem großen Polster wohl
weiter reagieren seine Partei hat die
Wahl mit deutlichem Vorsprung gewonnen
wir lassen uns das jetzt von Matthias
vorn auf MZ der Wahlstudio in Kiel ganz
genau zeigen hallo Matthias wie sehen
denn die aktuellsten Zahlen jetzt aus
hallo guten Abend wir schauen direkt auf
die zweite Hochrechnung heute abend
Punkt 19 Uhr und hier kommt sie demnach
kommt in Schleswig-Holstein die CDU auf
42,1 Prozent die SPD auf 15,6 grüne 18,4
zweitstärkste Partei FDP 6,9 AFD 4,5%
und wäre damit nicht im Parlament und
der SSW 6,2 der wäre drin unter den 6,3%
anderen übrigens auch die Linke mit
unter zwei Prozent wir schauen mal auf
Gewinne und Verluste im Kieler Landtag
und da sehen wir ganz deutliche
Zugewinne bei der regierenden CDU noch
deutlichere Verluste 11,7 Punkte bei der
SPD die Grünen gewinnen dazu 5,5 Punkte
die FDP verliert 4,6 auch die AFD
verliert 1,4 und der SSW kommt mit 2,9
mehr auf sein bestes Ergebnis seit sehr
sehr langer Zeit was heißt das für die
Sitzverteilung im Kieler Landtag wir
gehen im Moment von 73 sitzen aus die
gab es bishers können ein paar mehr noch
werden im Laufe des Abends je nachdem
wie viel Direktmandate die CDU gewinnt
die absolute Mehrheit liegt bei 37 die
CDU käme auf 34 die SPD auf 13 Sitze
grüne 15 FDP 6 und ssw5 die dann auf
jeden Fall drin weil die 5% Hürde für
sie ja nicht gilt was heißt das fürs
Regieren hier in Schleswig-Holstein das
ist die entscheidende Linie diese
senkrechte absolute damals 37 sitze da
muss man hin oder rüber Schwarz-Grün
schafft das locker Schwarz-Gelb schafft
es etwas knapper aber auch noch recht
deutlich Jamaika mit drei Parteien
natürlich sowieso CDU mit SPD auch das
ist satt möglich und die CDU mit dem
südschlesischen wählerverband sogar das
hätte eine Mehrheit mit anderen Worten
die CDU hat hier offensichtlich die Qual
der Wahl vielen Dank Matthias deutlicher
Vorsprung also für die CDU die auf jeden
Fall weiter regieren wird mit wem ist
dann eben die große Frage 1 steht fest
es war die große Popularität von Daniel
Günther die dazu geführt hat dass es
dieses cdu-wahlergebnis gibt er so wie
die anderen Spitzenkandidaten sind jetzt
im Gespräch in unseren Kieler Wahlstudio
und zwar mit Bettina Schausten bitte
Bettina
ja so ist es und wir beginnen auch mit
dem Wahlsieger dem CDU
Ministerpräsidenten Daniel Günther und
einer gewissen Paradoxie Herr Günther
sie wollten mit ihrem Regierungsbündnis
Jamaika weitermachen nun sind sie dafür
zu erfolgreich worauf stehen die Zeichen
jetzt Schwarz-Grün Schwarz-Gelb erstmal
freue ich mich natürlich darüber dass
wir so ein super Ergebnis bekommen haben
als CDU so dass der Regierungsauftrag
auch klar ist aber ich habe vor der Wahl
ja immer dafür geworben Jamaika
vorzusetzen merkt ja auch zwei Drittel
der Wählerinnen und Wähler haben den
drei Parteien auch ihre Stimme gegeben
und für mich ist vollkommen klar auch in
dieser Situation dass wir natürlich auch
mit Grünen und FDP ein Gespräch jetzt
führen werden das was ich vorher
angekündigt habe gilt natürlich auch
nach der Wahl
Müller Spitzenkandidat der
fdp-11,7% dramatische Verluste haben sie
schon irgendeine Analyse einer Erklärung
also erstmal herzlichen Glückwunsch an
Daniel Günther das ist wirklich ein
beeindruckender Sieg deine Günther hat
es geschafft die seine Popularität auch
in Stimmen für die CDU umzusetzen für
uns war von Anfang an klar das ist eine
große Herausforderung ist dieser
Wahlkampf wir sind gegen einen der
beliebtes Ministerpräsident der
Bundesrepublik angegangen gegen eine
beliebte Landesregierung haben uns
selber gleichzeitig neu aufgestellt
personell und auch inhaltlich und dann
ist natürlich der Ukraine Krieg der viel
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen hat die
Menschen waren sehr besorgt hier auch in
Schleswig-Holstein das heißt wir konnten
mit unseren Themen und auch mit unserem
Ansätzen nicht wirklich durchkommen ja
das die Grünen Spitzenkandidatin und
Finanzministerin ist Monika Heinold und
sie wollte ja eigentlich
Ministerpräsidentin werden das hat nicht
geklappt aber sie haben dazu gewonnen
sind Zweite geworden haben sie sich
heute Abend schon beworben bei Daniel
Günther für eine weitere Koalition
also ich habe ihm selbstverständlich
einmal gratuliert und dieses
Wahlergebnis zeigt ja dass die Politik
der letzten fünf Jahre honoriert wird
und es zeigt dass neben der CDU wir
Grüne die wahlgewinnerin sind die
Menschen in Schleswig-Holstein wollen
eine moderne Politik eine Politik die
nach vorne geht und deshalb war es sehr
gut dass wir als Grüne gesagt haben wir
wollen ganz vorne mitspielen und
deutlich machen wohin die Reise gehen
würde und wird wenn wir Grüne mit
Regierungsverantwortung tragen das
würden wir gerne auch zukünftig machen
Bernd Buchholzer Wirtschaftsminister im
Lande von der FDP sie wollten 15 Prozent
erreichen jetzt sind sieben Wasser
schief gelaufen im Wahlkampf ja da ist
ein Ministerpräsident der ziemlich viel
abgesammelt hat von der Zufriedenheit
die Grüne und FDP durchaus auch mit
verursacht haben im Landes muss man
leidlos anerkennen Glückwunsch dazu man
muss aber eben auch sagen es ist jetzt
ja möglich eine Regierung auch in der
Mitte
weiterzuführen dazu stehen wir bereit
wir haben immer gesagt wir wollen mit
Daniel Günther weiter regieren andere
wollten anders weiterregieren jetzt muss
man sehen was daraus wird wir stehen
dafür zur Verfügung in der Mitte
mitzumachen
Lars Harms der Spitzenkandidat des
südschweigischen wählerverbands
Minderheit der Dänen und Friesen und
freut sich heute Abend weil es ist etwas
gelungen was seit glaube ich seit 1950
nicht gelungen ist sie haben locker die
5% Hürde genommen an die sie gar nicht
gebunden sind sie könnten jetzt
eigentlich auch mitregieren das würde
eine Mehrheit tatsächlich ergeben werden
sie sich anbieten
regnerisch ist alles möglich aber Daniel
Günther ist derjenige der einlädt oder
muss er einladen selbstverständlich sind
wir immer zu Gesprächen bereit das haben
wir vorher gesagt dass wir zu allen
Gesprächen mit allen demokratischen
Parteien bereit sind dass wir in dem
Fall natürlich auch so aber das ist sein
Job das zu machen wir freuen uns jetzt
erstmal dass wir tatsächlich das beste
Ergebnis in der Geschichte als SSW
geholt haben noch nie hat der SSW sechs
Prozent bekommen und das macht uns
unheimlich stolz und ich glaube heute
werden wir uns erstmal nur damit
beschäftigen dass wir richtig ordentlich
feiern so und letzte Frage an den
Ministerpräsidenten und Wahlsieger Kiel
ist heute nächsten Sonntag ist
Düsseldorf
wie viel Rückenwind ist das für ihren
cdu-kollegen Hendrik wüst und natürlich
ist das Rückenwind auch für mein Freund
Henrik wüst auch für die CDU in
Nordrhein-Westfalen aber ich glaube man
muss schon sagen es ist eine
Landtagswahl hier in Schleswig-Holstein
gewesen die hier stattgefunden hat das
hat auch was damit zu tun dass wir eine
erfolgreiche Regierung haben ich finde
das muss man auch respektieren ich sag
das ausdrücklich hier auch Richtung
grüne und auch FDP in der Tat ist die
Zufriedenheit zu einem großen Teil auch
bei uns als CDU gelandet darüber freue
ich mich natürlich aber klar ist das
natürlich ein großartiger Wahlsieg für
die CDU und ich glaube das wird der CDU
Nordrhein-Westfalen nicht schaden und
vor allem ein Wahlerfolg für für Daniel
Günther der sicherlich jetzt auch in
Berlin künftig eine größere Rolle
spielen wird und damit geben wir zurück
hier von der Kieler Förde nach Mainz
Dankeschön Bettina und bis später der
Ausgang der schleswig-Holstein war
natürlich auch spannend auch
aufschlussreich für die Bundespolitik
gerade für die CDU die bei den letzten
Wahlen ordentlich Federn lassen musste
aber natürlich auch für die anderen
Parteien erste Reaktionen des Abends aus
den jeweiligen Parteispitzen
ein schönes Ergebnis
schließlich-holstein hat gewählt und
schließlich-holstein hat Daniel Günther
und der CDU das Vertrauen ausgesprochen
Schleswig-Holstein hält Kurs und die
Wählerinnen und Wähler haben das heute
entschieden jetzt ist die FDP auf der
Höhe der durchschnittlichen Ergebnisse
der letzten Jahrzehnte mehr wäre
wünschenswert gewesen aber immerhin dies
wir sehen glaube ich vor allem dass
unsere gute Arbeiten der Regierung in
den letzten Jahren belohnt wurde weil es
ein großes Vertrauen gibt es geht heute
Abend einen klaren Wahlsieger mit Daniel
Günther auch herzlichen Glückwunsch an
Ihnen es gibt aber mehrere Wahl Gewinne
genau zwei und das sind eben auch wir
Grüne und daraus sind wir verdammt stolz
das Ergebnis für die SPD ist bitter und
eine herbe Enttäuschung aber die SPD im
Jahr
2022 lässt sich durch Rückschläge nicht
mehr verunsichern wir haben die Partei
als Partei zuletzt gezeigt wie schnell
wir durch Geschlossenheit und durch
Entschlossenheit wieder nach vorne
kommen können wir haben uns sicherlich
vorgenommen wieder in Tag einzuziehen
und der Abend ist noch lang wie man so
schön sagt sie haben es gerade selbst
gesagt in der ARD sind wir bei 4,9 es
hat in Hamburg ähnliche Züge gehabt also
wir warten wir den Abend ab ich bin noch
Zuversicht dass wir wieder hier
einziehen
soweit also die Stimmen aus der
Bundespolitik weitere Analysen mehr
Stimmen und Hochrechnungen gibt es
direkt nach dieser heute-Sendung außer
unserem Wahlstudio und jederzeit online
in unserer ZDF heute App wir kommen
jetzt zum anderen großen Thema der
Sendung dem weltkriegsgedenken in einer
Zeit in der aktuell in Europa wieder
Soldaten und Zivilisten sterben und das
heute genau 77 Jahre nach dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkriegs mai 1945 Rams in
Frankreich Generaloberst Jodl
unterschreibt im US-Hauptquartier die
bedingungslose Kapitulation der
deutschen Wehrmacht sie tritt in Kraft
am 8 mai die Sowjetunion will aber ihre
eigene Zeremonie und darum unterzeichnet
generalfeldmarscheid Keitel eine weitere
Urkunde in Berlin Karl Post in der Nacht
zum 9 mai zwei Dokumente 2 Gedenktage
und heute in Berlin Erinnerung an die
Befreiung vom Nationalsozialismus
Henriette de Maizière
es ist ein Gedenken unter dem Eindruck
des russischen Angriffskrieges in der
Ukraine André Melnik ukrainischer
Botschafter liegt einen Kranz am
sowjetischen Ehrenmal in Berlin
Tiergarten nieder und Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz wendet sich mit einer
Fernsehansprache an die Menschen darin
betont er es sei geschichtsverfälschend
und in Farm wie Putin den Angriffskrieg
mit dem Kampf gegen den
Nationalsozialismus gleichsetze in der
gegenwärtigen Lage kann dies nur
bedeuten wir verteidigen Recht und
Freiheit an der Seite der angegriffenen
wir unterstützen die Ukraine im Kampf
gegen den orgressor
das nicht zu tun hier ist sie zu
kapitulieren vor blanker Gewalt und den
Aggressor zu bestärken dieser 8 Mai sei
wie kein anderer es gehe buchstäblich um
Krieg und Frieden
aus vielen Äußerungen die ich dieser
Tage höre spricht ernste Sorge Sorge
auch davor dass sich der Krieg ausweitet
dass der Frieden auch bei uns in Gefahr
geraten könnte
es wäre falsch das einfach abzutun
solche Sorgen müssen ausgesprochen
werden können
gleichzeitig gilt Angst darf uns nicht
leben auf dem Bundeskongress des
Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbundes in Berlin
sagt Bundespräsident Frank-Walter
Steinmeier heute dieser Krieg sei ein
Bruch mit vielem was uns als
selbstverständlich galt es sei ein
Epochenbruch
diesem 8 mai ist der Traum des
gemeinsamen europäischen Hauses
gescheitert ein Albtraum ist an seine
Stelle getreten diese 8 Mai sein Tag des
Krieges
der Tag der Befreiung der 8 mai ist
heute der 74 Tag des Krieges gegen die
Ukraine ein Krieg in Europa
gewichtige reden heute die wir uns zu
einordnen lassen wollen Theo call in
Berlin der Bundespräsident spricht von
Epochenbruch der Bundeskanzler davon
dass es einen russischen diktatfrieden
nicht geben solle die Ukraine und
Deutschland würden dies nicht
akzeptieren wie muss man diese Worte
einordnen
nun bei beiden als die bisher klarsten
Worte Richtung Putin und beim Kanzler
sicher auch als das Bemühen das eigene
politische Handeln besser zu erklären
und beim Bundespräsidenten insbesondere
als er noch viel weitergehender Warnruf
die Verurteilung von Putin hätte bei
beiden kaum deutlicher ausfallen können
da ist von Barbarei die Rede und wenn
Putin von Entner zifizierung spreche
dann sei das ein Zitat perfider und
zynischer Missbrauch der Geschichte
gewinnen werde eher Putin den Krieg
nicht so sagte der Kanzler es war aber
auch zugleich ein massiver Warnruf
insbesondere vom Bundespräsidenten der
gleich dreimal vom Epochenbruch sprach
viele Gewissheiten meinte er unseres
Lebens würden hinweggefegt das käme
gewaltige Veränderungen auf uns zu die
noch viel tiefer gehen als wir es
aktuell besprechen nicht zuletzt durch
den tiefen Einschnitt in die
Weltwirtschaft also das war rhetorisch
ein achter mai zwischen Zeitenwende und
Epochenbruch danke theocall nach Berlin
und die ganze Ansprache des
Bundeskanzlers die sehen Sie bei uns im
ZDF um 19 Uhr
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bass nahm
heute im Kiew angedenkfeierlichkeiten
zum 8 mai Teil traf unter anderem auch
ukrainische Präsident silenski auch die
First Lady Jill Biden kam zu einem
Überraschungsbesuch in die Ukraine und
gleichzeitig wird und wurde weiter
gekämpft auch heute gab es
Opfer zu beklagen Tobias Häfner
viel zu löschen gibt es nicht mehr für
die Feuerwehr in bilo horefka in der
Ostukraine die frühere Schule völlig
zerstört von einem russischen Angriff
zwei Menschen die hier eigentlich Schutz
gesucht hatten wurden tot geborgen und
60 werden noch unter dem Schutt vermutet
Russland verbindet seine Bilder für die
Fernsehschirme in der Heimat nicht mit
menschlichen Tragödien alles seien
präzise gewählte Ziele auch das
ukrainische Militär veröffentlicht
Aufnahmen die hier zeigen offenbar wie
ein russischer Hubschrauber auf der
strategisch wichtigen Schlangeninsel im
Schwarzen Meer abgeschossen wird
viele Ukraine gedenken heute auch des
Zweiten Weltkriegs und spüren
internationale Unterstützung Justin
trudau Kanadas premier besuchte bereits
Kiews zerstörtes Umland
Bärbel Baas die Bundestagspräsidentin
kam Herr Zug dorthin informierte sich im
zerbomben ihre PIN und sagte Hilfe zu
mir ist auch wichtig dass sie relativ
schnell für die Menschen die
mittlerweile zurückgekommen sind hier in
diese Stadt auch insbesondere für die
Kinder Kindergärten Schulen eine
medizinische Versorgung bekommen
Präsident selensky bedankte sich für das
Votum des Bundestags zu
Waffenlieferungen erhofft sich aber noch
mehr
ich fordere Sie auf uns auch beim Thema
EU-Beitritt zu unterstützen ihr Kollege
Friedrich Merz hat uns da viele
Hoffnungen gemacht bei seinem Besuch
hier
in vielen Familien ist der zweite
Weltkrieg heute besonders präsent sie
schauen Aufnahmen an in so manch altem
Fotoalbum wie bei Julia und Larissa
schurdruck in Odessa
aktuell fliegen hier jeden Tag Raketen
mein Vater hat damals gekämpft für einen
friedlichen Himmel über uns und nun
unsere Kinder aus Angst in dunklen
Kellern möge Gott die Angreifer stoppen
sie wollen uns auslöschen das ist nicht
nur krieg hier
aber irgendwann so sagt es die
Großmutter Tochter und Enkelin werde man
hoffentlich einen Feiertag für den Sieg
in diesem Krieg haben
wir sprechen mit Katrin Eigendorf in
Kiew Katrin du hattest die Gelegenheit
mit der ukrainischen Staatsspitze zu
sprechen welche Signale gab es da
ja ich hatte die Gelegenheit mit
außenministerkulierbar über das
deutsch-ukrainische Verhältnis an diesem
Tag heute auch zu sprechen und
interessant ist er hat da sehr in die
Zukunft geguckt und hat gesagt das
Verhältnis hat sich deutlich verbessert
aber die Erwartungen der Ukraine an
Deutschland als Führungsnation und
größten Staat in Europa sind eben auch
extrem hoch und er sagte wir Ukrainer
sind eben sehr ehrlich und sehr direkt
und wir machen klar was wir von
Deutschland erwarten und wir erwarten
von Deutschland das ist noch mehr und
deutlicher für die Ukraine einsteht
Präsident selenskis Antwort ging in eine
ähnliche Richtung er sagte was er
erwartet ist dass insgesamt die Europäer
doch der Ukraine noch viel mehr
Vertrauen müssten und darauf setzen
müssen da eben dass die Ukraine ein
europäischer Staat ist also auch in die
Zukunft geblickt aber interessant
natürlich das auch an diesem Tag an dem
wichtigen Gedenktag dem Gedenktag an die
Opfer des Nationalsozialismus des
Angriffs Kriegs gegen die Ukraine man
viel mehr die Opfer im Prinzip des
russischen angriffskriegs in den
Vordergrund gestellt hat ein Besuch auch
von Parlamentspräsidentin Bars der in
schutzsicherer Weste stattfand und wo es
darum ging wie kann Deutschland an der
Seite der Ukraine in der Zukunft stehen
Dankeschön Katrin nach Kiew und am 8 Mai
auch dieses Signal die Sanktionen gegen
Russland sollen nochmals verschärft
werden die führenden westlichen
Industrienationen die G7 haben sich
darauf geeinigt ein Öl Embargo gegen
Russland zu verhängen danach sollen die
Importe schrittweise auslaufen
Corona Dürren und jetzt der Krieg das
treibt die Lebensmittelpreise massiv in
die Höhe entwicklungsministerin Schulze
befürchtet dass die größte Hungersnot
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg droht mit
Millionen Toten in der Bild am Sonntag
sagte sie die Lage sei hoch dramatisch
sie forderte keine Nahrungsmittel mehr
zu Biokraftstoffen zu verarbeiten
der neue
CSU-Generalsekretär Martin Huber sieht
sich mit Plagiatsvorwürfen konfrontiert
die hatte einen Expertin der Bild am
Sonntag erhoben allein auf den ersten
Seiten der Doktorarbeit finden sich
mehrere Zitate ohne oder mit falscher
Quellenangabe kündigte an seine
Dissertation von der
Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität in
München überprüfen zu lassen
in der chinesischen
Sonderverwaltungszone Hongkong wurde ein
neuer Regierungschef gewählt der frühere
Sicherheitsminister John Lee erhielt von
einem pekingtreuen Wahlkomitee und 99
Prozent der Stimmen er war der einzige
Kandidat Lee hatte eine zentrale Rolle
bei der Niederschlagung der
Demokratiebewegung vor drei Jahren
jetzt sind die USA dort könnte bald das
bundesweite Recht auf Abtreibung kippen
deshalb sind erneut viele Frauen aber
auch Männer auf die Straße gegangen sie
demonstrierten dafür Abtreibungen auch
weiterhin zu erlauben dabei skandierten
sie Abtreibung ist ein Menschenrecht
Anfang der Woche war bekannt geworden
dass der oberste US-Gerichtshof das
Recht auf eine legale Abtreibung
möglicherweise abschaffen will mit einer
endgültigen Entscheidung wird in den
nächsten zwei Monaten gerechnet
jetzt der Sport und Kristin und ganz
viel Jubel beim Fußball Ladies first die
Frauen des VfL Wolfsburg sind zum
siebten Mal deutsche fußballmeisterinnen
natürlich große Freude am vorletzten
Spieltag den sie mit einem 10:1 Kanter
Erfolg bei Absteiger FC Carl Zeiss Jena
gründen
Jubel bei den Wolfsburger Fußballerinnen
nach dem heutigen Show laufen gegen Jena
sie sind das Maß der Dinge im deutschen
Frauenfußball erstes Tor durch Eva payor
nach acht Minuten den siebten Treffer
erzielt nationalstürmerin Alex Popp nach
dem Wechsel das zehnte und letzte Tor
geht dann auf das Konto von Svenja Huth
10:1 dann wurde der Trainer gejagt
Tommys droht getauft von Alex Popp mit
Sekt
ich komme doch durchaus nicht drumherum
heute wahrscheinlich von daher lieber
direkt beim ersten Mal okay
sensationell sensationell die Saison für
die Wolfsburgerinnen folgen soll jetzt
noch der Titel im DFB-Pokal
im ersten Sonntagsspiel bei den Männern
trennten sich Frankfurt und Gladbach 1:1
wobei die Eintracht einige Profis wegen
des Europa League Finals geschont hat
und kurz vor Schluss steht es bei Bayern
München gegen den VfB Stuttgart 2:2 das
wäre ein wichtiger Punkt für den VfB im
Kampf um den Klassenerhalt aber noch ist
es nicht entschieden mehrere Verletzte
das ist die unschöne Seite des
unbändigen Jubels mit Platzsturm bei
Schalke 04 Wiederaufstieg geschafft die
Königsblauen völlig aus dem Häuschen
die Feier war schon mal erstklassig
Schalke 04 zurück in der ersten Liga an
einem Abend der an aufstiegsdramaturgie
kaum zu überbieten war
ein Rückstand hier noch drei zu gewinnen
ist einfach grandios erst die 78 minute
brachte die Erlösung das Siegtor von
Salazar zum 3:2 gleichbedeutend mit der
Gewissheit der erstlig gab es die nennt
zwar nur ein einjähriges Kapitel das tut
der Königsblauen Seele ebenso gut wie
dem Geldbeutel des Vereins die
Finanzlage nach der Trennung von Gazprom
angespannt Schalke also zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt wieder oben dabei
und ich habe noch einen Aufsteiger
Eintracht Braunschweig ist Abkommen der
Saison zweitklassig Kaiserslautern muss
in die Relegation gegen Dresden viel los
viel los vielen Dank Christin wir
schauen schnell und fix auf die
Wetteraussichten für morgen die Sonne
scheint von einem oft wolkenlosen Himmel
nur am Alpenrand kann es am Nachmittag
auch mal ein Gewitter geben die
Temperatur steigt auf Werte von 17 bis
26 Grad
im heute-journal um 21 Uhr interviewt
Christian Sievers den
schleswig-holsteinischen Wahlsieger so
viele von uns danke fürs Interesse und
gerne bis morgen um